Speaker 1: Democrats are increasingly turning,
some are saying, on Democratic Senator from
California, Dianne Feinstein, and demanding that
she resign. Let me remind everybody what is going
on. And there's a lot of sad stuff going on in
this story. Dianne Feinstein is currently the
longest serving member of the U.S. Senate. She is
89 years old. She is she has announced she is not
seeking reelection in 2024. There have been many
concerns. I want to be as respectful as possible,
but also be accurate. There have been
many concerns for years now about Dianne
Feinstein's cognitive state. There are
public examples. Tough to watch, I admit.
Public examples of Dianne Feinstein asking a
witness during a Senate hearing a question.
Hearing an answer from the witness and then
looking down at her papers and asking the
exact same question a second time, seemingly
forgetting that she just asked that question.
There are endless reports from staffers and
people in D.C. who work at the Senate saying
Dianne Feinstein regularly will meet someone that
she has met many times before, even recently,
and has no recollection of having met that
person. So. Listen, I mean, we don't have a
diagnosis here, but there have been concerns for
years about this. As far as Dianne Feinstein goes,
it is the right decision at this point. She had a
great run to not run for reelection in 2024. What
has surfaced in the wake of this is that there is
a primary in California in which three members of
the House of Representatives have decided to
run for Dianne Feinstein Senate seat. That's
Adam Schiff, who we've interviewed, Barbara Lee,
who we're going to interview, and Katie Porter,
who we would like to interview, but so far has
not responded to our requests. You can't run for
House and Senate at the same time, meaning that
while all three of them, Barbara Lee, Adam Schiff
and Katie Porter, who are mid-seventies early
sixties and around 50 years old respectively,
while they are all competing for the Senate
seat, their congressional seats are now going
to be open because they can't run for both at
the same time. Dianne Feinstein, on top of this,
as is reported by Newsweek, has recently been out
with shingles. And this is particularly impactful
because Dianne Feinstein is on the Judiciary
Committee. And when you have such a divided
government the way we have right now, where
Democrats barely control the Senate, judicial
appointees are one of the relatively few ways that
Democrats can assert power, use their majority,
and try to assist Joe Biden in getting things done
because of Dianne Feinstein's absence from that
committee. It has effectively made it impossible
for Senate Democrats to continue confirming Joe
Biden's judicial nominations. So both because it
would potentially allow a different dynamic in
the primary, which would be better for Democrats
and because of this issue on the Senate Judiciary.
More and more Democrats are saying that Dianne
Feinstein should resign right now. If Dianne
Feinstein did resign and Farron Cousins talked
about this one filling in for me last week,
to some degree, the governor of California,
currently Democratic Governor Gavin Newsom, would
get to replace appoint a replacement to fill the
vacancy. Now, you have to understand that there
are different dynamics in California depending on
how long it is until the next general election. If
Dianne Feinstein were to resign within six months
of the general election, there wouldn't be a
special election for the seat. You would just wait
until the general election. When you have under
I'm sorry, when you have more than 180 days left,
then you would do a special election. Right now,
because we have more than 180 days until the 2024
election. If Dianne Feinstein resigned today,
you would see the appointment by Gavin Newsom
and then you would see a special election that
is potentially a much better path forward, both,
number one, because of its impact on the Senate
Judiciary Committee. And number two, because
it might actually change the game with regard
to so many Democratic open seats in the House of
Representatives that increasingly Democrats are
saying that is exactly what should be done. It
doesn't appear as though right now there is big
momentum for Dianne Feinstein to actually do
that. And it's unclear whether that is going
to change. The other aspect to this that's being
discussed is what about appointing a replacement
on the Judiciary Committee for Dianne Feinstein?
I don't have a lot of news to give you about
that right now, but it is certainly something
that is being discussed. My leaning right now.
Is that it would probably be a good
idea for Dianne Feinstein to resign.
What exactly the timing of that would be. And
this issue of the replacement versus getting back
to the Senate Judiciary Committee, I don't know.
It's not about again, it's not about stigmatizing.
It's not about making fun of anyone. It's not
about any of these things. It's about political
expediency. And Feinstein has had an incredible
run in the Senate, has accomplished so much,
iconic in so many different ways. Nothing
is being taken away from her. In my mind,
if she did resign. Republicans are jumping all
over this and saying she should not resign.
And now Democrats are being bad in some way
by urging her to do so. This is, of course,
Republicans concerned only with self-preservation
and realizing that it's actually been a great
thing for them that Joe Biden's judicial nominees
have been held up as a result of this. So I,
quite frankly, could not care less what
Republicans say. They just want whatever
is best for them. It does seem overall that what's
best for the Senate and what's best for Democrats
would be for Dianne Feinstein to resign. I'm
willing to change my mind. If you disagree with
me, simply let me know in a comment. In an email?
In a tweet. The David Pakman Show is an audience
funded program. We primarily depend on your
support to fund what we do to pay staff salaries,
health insurance, connectivity, the plants that
are behind me. All of it. Yes, all of it is funded
directly by you. You can sign up at join Packman
dot com. We do an extra show every single day for
our members called The Bonus Show. We also offer
commercial free audio and video streams of the
show. Whether you prefer to listen or watch,
both are made available commercial free to
you. We also do members only town halls. The next
one is coming up soon. We also have a soundboard,
a member soundboard with a lot of the clips
I play on the show off of my soundboard.
Speaker 3: Thank you. Your lucky
stars every day. You're not David.
Speaker 1: Pakman. Well, easy there, Alex. Those
are made available to our members as well. On
The David Pakman Show website you can sign up at
join Packman dot com. It's a great, great thing